graph the line that represents a
proportional relationship between y and
X with a unit rate 0.4 that is a change
of one unit in X corresponds to a change
of 0.4 units in Y and they also ask us
to figure out what the equation of this
line actually is let me get my scratch
pad out if we can think about it so
let's just think about some potential x
and y values here so let's think about
some potential x and y values so when
we're thinking about proportional
relationships that means that Y is going
to be equal to some constant times X so
if we have a proportional relationship
if you have zero X's it doesn't matter
what your constant here is you're going
to have zero Y's so the point 0 0 should
be on your line so this is the point 0 0
this should be on my line right over
there now let's think about what happens
as we increase X so if X goes from 0 to
1 we already know that a change of one
unit in X corresponds to a change of 0.4
units in Y so if x increases by 1 then Y
is going to increase by 0.4 it's not so
easy to graph this one come as 0.4 0.4
is hard to graph on this on this little
tool right over here so let's try to get
this to be a whole number so then when x
increases another one Y is going to
increase by 0.4 again it's going to get
to 0.8 when x increases again by 1 then
Y is going to increase by 0.4 again it's
going to get to 1.2 if x increases again
Y is going to increase by 0.4 again so
just 1 point 6 notice every time X is
increasing by 1 Y is increasing by 0.4
that's exactly what they told us here
now if x increases by 1 again to 5 then
Y is going to increase 0.422 and I like
this point because this is nice and easy
to graph so we see that the point 0 0
and the point 5 comma 2 5 comma 2 should
be on this graph and I could draw it and
I'm going to do it on the tool in a
second as well so it looks something
something like something like this and
notice the slope of this actual graph
over here notice the slope of this
actual graph if we if our change in X if
our change in X
five so notice here our change in X is
five our change in X is five you see
that as well when you go from zero to
five your this change in X is five
change in X is equal to five
what was our corresponding change in Y
well our corresponding change in Y when
our change in X was five our change in Y
was equal to two and you see that here
when X went from zero to five Y went
from zero to two so our change in Y in
this circumstance is equal to two so our
slope which is change in Y over change
in x over change in X it's the rate of
change of your vertical axis with
respect to your horizontal axis is going
to be equal to
it's going to be equal to two over five
or 2/5 which if you wrote as the decimal
is equal to zero point four so this
right over here is your slope so I'm
going to do this with the tool but first
let's also think about what the equation
of this of this line is going to be well
we know that Y is equal to some constant
times X and we know that the point five
two is on this line right over here so
we could say well when X is equal to
five Y is equal to two or when y equals
two we have K times 5 or K is equal to
dividing both sides by five dividing
both sides by five you can't see that so
if I divide both sides by five I'm left
with K is equal to 2/5 which makes sense
we're used to seeing this when we have Y
is equal to something times X this
something right over here is going to be
our slope so the equation of the line is
y is equal to 0.4 X so let's fill this
in let's actually do the exercise now so
we had two points one was the point zero
zero when x is 0 Y is 0 and when X is 5
y is zero point four times that so it's
Y is equal to two and we said the
equation is y
is equal to 0.4 times X so let's check
our answer